où on va peu importe ce qu'on achète 9la
sion nous rattrape c'est
particulièrement vrai à la station
service en tant que livreur sur mon jeu
comme je pense à notre charge de travail
je serai pas mal non moins cher et mon
argent mais c'est la classe moyenne y en
a qui n'ont pu je dois choisir août va
dépenser son argent outre l'essence des
hausses de prix importantes ont aussi
été observées au cours de la dernière
année pour les véhicules neufs et usagés
les vêtements le logement et les
aliments que ce soit l'épicerie ou au
restaurant des monnaies on est capable
d'élever qui mange il apparaît de la cam
en date est sa cote à l'inflation a
atteint 8,1 pour cent au pays en juin
comparativement à l'an dernier un sommet
inégalé depuis 1983 pendant ce temps les
salaires ont progressé de 5,2 pour ça
résultat les canadiens voient leur
pouvoir d'achat diminuer sa touche
particulièrement les personnes qui sont
à plus faibles revenus ou dont les
revenus sont excédentaires donc certains
retraités par exemple qui ne voient pas
leur leur prestation augmenter certains
ménages devront donc refaire leur budget
ça peut vouloir dire faire des choix qui
sont peut-être plus déchirant faut
vraiment faire un ordre de priorité voir
quels sont les défenses sont
prioritaires quelles sont les choses
qu'on pourrait peut-être retarder on
peut penser au cellulaire on peut penser
à des abonnements dans trois services de
télécommunications ben écoutez pour
faire un tour de piste nature il faut se
ramener à l'essentiel pour calmer la
surchauffe
la banque du canada a fait grimper son
taux directeur deux points d'eux ni pour
cent la semaine dernière un geste pour
encourager les ménages à épargner plutôt
que dépenser ta bande que l'élève
vraiment à l'attack par rapport à
déflation ou petit monétaires et des
taux d'intérêt plus élevés devrait
éventuellement freiner la demande ce qui
pourrait amener naturellement leur un
ralentissement de l'inflation aulas et
les hausses de taux d'intérêt ne sont
pas terminées la banque du canada estime
qu'elle devra de nouveau aussi son taux
directeur pour endiguer l'inflation ici
olivier vachon radio canada montréal